Паркування під знаком, який це забороняє.
Впритул до зебри чи просто на ній.
Паркування на тротуарах.На смузі для руху.
Згідно з новим законом про паркування, який набув чинності наприкінці вересня,
подібного на вулицях українських міст вже не має бути.
Всі ці машини мають бути евакуйовані, аводії - оштрафовані паркувальними інспекторами.
У цих випадках водії мали би сплатити щонайменше 500 гривень штрафу.
У першу чергу я як інспекторевакуювала б цей автомобіль,
який знаходиться назупинці громадського транспорту.
Потім ми би перейшли до автомобілів, які стоять у пішохідній зоні. Теж евакуація.
29-річна Аліна Ярош має досвід роботи інспектором автобусних пасажирських перевезень
і тепер хоче стати паркувальним інспектором.
Вона подала свої документи в КМДА
і разом з іще 15-ма охочими пройшла перший з трьох турів співбесіди.
Департамент транспорту хоче набрати загалом 50 інспекторів,
які будуть наводити лад на першому етапі впровадження реформи паркування:
в трьох центральних районах Києва - Шевченківському, Печерському та Голосіївському.
Однак поки реформа існує, фактично, лише на папері.
Конкурсний відбір інспекторів не завершено.
Не вирішене й питання, в якій формі вони працюватимуть.
Ми орієнтуємося на закордонний досвід. Це американські.
У них кольори форми наближені до фіолетового.
У нас буде літня, зимова форма. Буде і жіноча.
Для цього владі ще треба провести тендер на закупівлю уніформи.
А також тендер на закупівлю техніки для роботи інспекторів -
обладнання, яким вони фіксуватимуть порушення.
Ще не до кінця урядомухвалені деякі піднормативні акти
щодо затвердження списку обладнання, якеми можемо використовувати для фотофіксації.
Ще не до кінцяухвалені відповідніінструкції, на підставі яких діятиме інспектор.
І міська влада ще має затвердити штатний розклад інспекції.
Коли це все буде виконано, інспекція буде створена.
У Департаменті транспорту і інфраструктури зізнаються,
що були б раді вже нині бачити паркувальних інспекторів на вулицях столиці.
За допомогою естонських, німецьких експертів розробляли алгоритми дій інспекторів
та думали про логістику розташування парковок.
У центрі Києва влада поки що не може забезпечити усім місця на офіційних парковках - їх замало.
До того ж, платити тут доведеться за найвищим тарифом - 10 грн на годину.
Кому це задорого або не вистачить місць,
має залишити машину в іншому районі і скористатися громадським транспортом.
Як уся ця теорія виглядатимена практиці,
вКМДА обіцяють продемонструвати не раніше початку наступного року.
Проте, за оцінками експертів групи"Реанімаційний пакет реформ для Києва",
виконання нового закону про паркування може затягнутися аж до весни.
Як повідомила на своїй сторінці в Facebook експертка групи Оксана Величко,
досі не вирішене питання щодо придбання
автоматичної системи контролю за оплатою паркування - АСКОП.
АСКОП - це програма в планшеті паркувального інспектора.
Через неї інспектор перевірятиме, чи сплатив водій за паркування
через 10 хвилин після зупинки та скільки загалом годин паркування оплатив.
Ось такі паркомати, задля економії коштів на їхнє обслуговування, поступово зникнуть.
Платити за паркування можна будеза допомогою спеціального додатку для сматрфонів,
через смс або оператора мобільного зв’язку.
Відповідно до нового закону про паркування,
паркувальні інспектори мають з’явитися в усіх українських містах.
Наразі закон, схоже, виконується лише у Львові.
Тут до роботи стали перші п’ять інспекторів.
За допомогою мобільного додатку вони фіксують порушення
і можуть виписувати штрафи, які надсилаються водієві поштою.
Планується, що штрафувати зможуть навіть так звані євробляхи -
тим доведеться сплатити штраф при перетині кордону.
Я би хотіла, щоб наші люди були психологічно готові до того,
щоінколи можна пройтися 500 метрів до місця парковки.
Аліна Ярош нетерпляче чекає того дня, коли вона зможе надіти форму інспектора,
а столиця ставатиме дедалі більш європейським містом,
де люди поважають один одного і виконують закони.
Заробітна платня інспектора в Києві становитиме трохи більше 10 тисяч гривень.
У КМДА вважають, цього достатньо, щоб інспектори не були ласі на хабар.